you often see products with labels
seeing green eco-friendly all-natural
if you're looking for the products that
are best for the environment
how do you know which ones to trust
when we look more closely we can
sometimes feel lied to or misled this is
called green washing
its purpose
to trick consumers into thinking a brand
or product is green when in fact it
isn't really
to make the right choices easy
we need labels and claims we can trust
how does the EU help
to fight greenwashing the commission
proposed new legislation it obliges
companies to prove their environmental
claims
introduces common criteria to check
these claims
encourages the use of scientifically
sound and reliable methods
for example the environmental footprint
methods scientists of the European
commission developed this method to help
companies measure and reduce the impact
of their product the mandatory new rules
will support EU voluntary initiatives
that already help tackling greenwashing
like the EU Eco label or the EU Eco
management and audit scheme EMASS result
with information we can trust we can
make truly sustainable choices
thank you